مبادره طريق مكه تواصل جهودها في خدمه
حجاج بيت الله الحرام في باكستان للعام
الثاني على التوالي منذ جائحه كورونا
حفاوه وترحيب رسمي حظيت به المبادره مع
ودائع اولى طلائح حجاج باكستان ضمن
المبادره واشاده بدور القياده السعوديه في
خدمه ضيوف الرحمن
نشكر خادم الحرمين الشريفين الملك سلمان
وولي عهده الامير محمد بن سلمان على
مبادره طريق مكه والخدمات والتسهيلات التي
يقدمانها للحجاج الشعب الباكستاني يكن كل
الاحترام والتقدير للسعوديه ونعتبرها
شقيقا اكبر نظيره مواقفها الداعمه
لباكستان العام هذا مستهدف اكثر من 26 الف
من مطار اسلام اباد نعمل ان شاء الله في
السنوات القادمه ان يتم التوسع في باكستان
الى مطار كراتشي ومطار لاهور المملكه
العربيه السعوديه وعلى راسها سيدي خادم
الحرمين الشريف الملك سلمان بن عبد العزيز
اسمه سيدي ولي العهد حريص كل الحرص على
خدمه الحجاج وهذا شرف لكل مواطن سعودي
اجراءات تنظيميه سلسه ومرنه لقد استحسان
حجاج باكستان الى بيت الله الحرام ضمن
مبادره طريق مكه بين ان الدقائق تمر طويله
على الحجاج الذين يتلهفون بكل شوق للوصول
الى الديار المقدسه في مكه المكرمه
والمدينه المنوره
اذكر الحكومه السعوديه على هذه المبادره
وسهوله الاجراءات هذه اول مره نحج فيها
انا وسبعه من افراد اسرتي انتظر هذه
اللحظه بعد توفر الامكانات عاقبه تقاعدي
تدربنا على مناسك الحج واكملنا كافه
الاجراءات المطلوبه
هذه المره الاولى التي اسافر فيها خارج
باكستان اشعر بالسعاده والشوق لزياره مسجد
الرسول في المدينه المنوره والكعبه
المشرفه واشكر الحكومتين الباكستانيه
والسعوديه على سهوله الاجراءات وضم
باكستان لهذه المبادره
مبادره طريق مكه تهدف الى تيسير رحله سفر
الحجاج عبر انهاء اجراءات جوازات وفحص
الاشتراطات الصحيه وتمييز الامتعه في
مطارات بلدانهم وايصالهم الى مقر اقامتهم
في الديار المقدسه
مبادره طريق مكه جزء من خطه طموحه
للارتقاء بخدمات ضيوف الرحمن ضمن رؤيه
2030 والتي تهدف الى اختصار الوقت والجهد
على الحجاج واداء فريضه الحج بكل يسر
وسهوله عبد الرحمن المزيني العربيه اسلام
اباد لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات